c'est un drame sans témoin qui sait
jouer hier soir vers 19h dans cette
maison de diancet en Côte-d'Or appelé
pour des coups de feu les secours ont
découvert une femme de 59 ans décédée
dans sa voiture près de son véhicule son
compagnon gisait mort lui aussi alors
selon le parquet de Dijon l'hypothèse
est la plus probable et celle d'un
féminicide suivi d'un suicide car un
fusil de chasse a été découvert sur les
lieux le couple possédait cette maison
alliancée depuis une vingtaine d'années
et dans le village toutes les personnes
que nous avons croisées sont sidérées
elles nous ont décrit un couple de
quinquagénaire sympathique qui fourmille
de projets deux enquêtes sont ouvertes
par la gendarmerie l'une pour homicide
volontaire concernant la femme l'autre
pour recherche des causes de la mort
l'auteur présumé de l'homicide était
jusqu'ici inconnue des services de
police perdent trois enfants majeurs
l'homme était directeur général d'une
grande société de services informatiques
installée à Dijon